we do have primary results from last
night the primary coverage was sort of
replaced in a great sense by this
horrible tragic mass shooting in uvalde
texas but there were primary results as
some of you know donald trump's new
obsession is his endorsement record now
i have to tell you it's all kind of
meaningless trump
mostly endorses people that are already
winning
or incumbents or obvious favorites and
so like your record when you're
endorsing mostly people that are
obviously going to win it doesn't really
mean that much but okay trump is
obsessed with his endorsement record
trump had some humiliating losses last
night i mean absolutely humiliating
losses in the
georgia gubernatorial a primary the
republican primary in georgia donald
trump endorsed david perdue the former
republican senator
on the other hand mike pence endorsed
brian kemp the incumbent georgia
governor it's not normal for a president
and a vice president so recently out of
office to be on the opposite sides of
races like this but trump endorsed david
perdue david perdue was crushed by more
than 50 points this is one of the most
humiliating losses in recent political
history among well-known candidates okay
sure often you've got an incumbent
against a no name and they win by 50.
fine this is a different situation this
was actually supposedly going to be a
real race and brian kemp defeated david
perdue 74-22
a stunning victory for kemp and a
trouncing for donald trump
we then went to the georgia republican
secretary of state primary this is a
really important race this is who
controls the election in the state of
georgia brad raffensberger easily
defeating jody heiss trump endorsed jody
heiss brad raffensberger won by nearly
20 points now trump got himself some
wins without a doubt herschel walker won
and uh etc but two
major major losses for the failed former
president now some other important
results from yesterday stacey abrams one
in georgia this was a formality this was
uh she was unopposed in the democratic
gubernatorial primary stacey abrams will
now face brian kemp in november that's a
really important election
and when we talk about
what are some of the most important
elections there are so many in november
but we've talked about how pennsylvania
senate could ultimately decide uh who
controls the senate in the next uh
congress that's going to be important
there's lots of really important racist
florida governor ron desantis running
there that could set the tone for 2024.
abrams versus kemp in georgia is a big
big deal now also from georgia in the
14th district yes marjorie taylor green
easily won her primary there was every
expectation that she would she had
roughly 70 of the vote marcus flowers
easily won on the democratic side so
they will face each other that's a
really great race to get involved in in
the sense that defeating marjorie taylor
green in particular after the defeat of
madison cawthorne it would be amazing
but as far as a general election
georgia's 14th district is very red and
it's going to be an uphill battle and
then lastly in the arkansas republican
gubernatorial primary as expected sarah
huckabee sanders easily won she's donald
trump's former white house press
secretary she will likely win the
governorship chris jones won the
democratic primary for governor and in
november it will be chris jones against
sarah huckabee sanders a very red state
it is you know speaking speaking
honestly with you it's difficult to
imagine that there would be a real
opportunity for chris jones there but
potentially another race to follow so
some humiliations for donald trump last
night when he posted um he posted today
to his platform truth social truth
essential yeah he barely spoke about the
ones that he lost focusing only on the
win so not not a major surprise um next
week more
primaries which we will be covering and
all of these stories will have more
coverage on our instagram which you can
find at david pakman show
as many of you know i'm a busy person i
don't always have the exact correct
nutritional plan for my meals every
single day and that's why i also take a
multivitamin and a couple of supplements
but doing them all separately can be a
little bit time consuming which is why
athletic greens is just fantastic and
they're one of our sponsors i've been
using the athletic greens since last
year it just really simplifies nutrition
i just do a scoop of the ag-1 and i'm
getting 75 high quality
vitamins and minerals and my probiotics
and it's all from whole food sources i
drink it in the morning i know i'm good
i don't have to be messing around with
different pills and supplements or
whatever spend time planning when what
time of day do i need to take each one i
just get it all with one scoop you can
put it in a smoothie you can drink it
straight it tastes great and then i'm
just good for the day
it supports gut health and i'm getting
everything that i need and i'm looking
for athletic greens is giving my
audience a free one-year supply of
vitamin d plus five free travel packs
when you go to athleticgreens.com
pacman and the link is down below